[Music]
what's up reject nation it's your boy
John Humphrey right here can't find my
hat little bummed about that but we
endure we move on you know what I was
actually kind of surprised this weekend
because looking at box office mojo the
new insidious movie has done pretty well
I guess this is kind of surprising I
mean I'd forgotten the movie was coming
out to be honest it seems like after
they bumped it there weren't advertising
it nearly as much but it brought in 29
point 26 million dollars according to
this the second largest debut of the
franchise topping the third chapter by
seven million ninth largest opening for
Blum House productions
topping the twenty nine million dollar
opening for paranormal activity for
franchises grossed now over four hundred
million dollars worldwide and hey man
I'm always excited to see the peeps over
at Blum House doing well and you know
I'm kind of surprised at the responses
to this movie it seems like what's
divisive but people are digging it some
people at least are digging it people
certainly showed up so I figured why not
check out what the rest of the world has
to say you guys already know my thoughts
if you haven't seen my review yet click
the card or you know wait around until
the end of this video I'm sure I'll put
it in the end screen also quick shouts
out to our video sponsors Stardust I'm
gonna be harvesting people's reactions
through Stardust right now actually if
you don't know it it's a great app that
allows you to record up to 30 second
reactions and reviews to any movie TV
show or trailer that comes out it's a
lot of fun to use a lot of people on
there some of your favorite youtubers as
well it's just everybody like just
normal people man and we're gonna hear
from a few of those folks right now so
let's turn up the sound let's see what
the people have to say right now
[Music]
okay I'm in the scream out loud but I
certainly curled up a few times and I'm
glad to see some enthusiasm maybe a bit
higher of a rating than I would have
given it but hey I'm just I'm just like
yeah I'm kind of with that guy I mean I
kind of disagree with the beginning
being boring for me the middle is
actually where a lot of the pacing
problems happen in this movie but even
though it seems like we enjoyed this my
different level I do agree there's some
really cool plot twists in there that
even if they are crowded you know are
still pretty good ideas and it does tie
into the first me I mean they all kind
of tie into each other and they do
somehow like space time warping stuff I
appreciated that as well good good catch
okay but I have never seen any of the
insidious movies before this one Wow I
was actually impressed it was quite good
I liked the fact it was actually an
older woman who was a hero where the
much of what teenagers I'm sure nice I
actually think that's cool especially
for somebody going in cold that's
definitely something I thought about
when I was watching this movies you know
representation is a thing and it's gotta
be cool as visually you are an older
person to see a movie like this like he
said not head up by teenagers led by you
know an older woman and a woman at that
you know an older woman like I think
that it really is a cool thing it's nice
to see the you know that is a kind of
resonant thing about this and it's
always gonna be the most complete if
you've seen them all but I like that you
know people who are seeing this without
having seen all the other ones they're
still kind of getting it obvious he was
by far the worst in the series I also
saw this with a terrible audience and
that did have to do so like that in my
mind I can't
blindspots of what happened maybe it was
a little entertaining or most of it but
I was a little bit let down mine and I
want to watch it begin because I feel
like I miss maybe some major plot points
you know what that's fair I've had some
pretty crappy screening experiences in
my life that have affected not only my
feelings about a movie but just how much
of it I was able to process at the time
namely I went to see Rob Zombie's
Halloween - which is a divisive movie
anyway but I went to see that on opening
night at like the only theatre I could
find it at it at City Walk I was in like
the front left that was all there was
left and the audience was so rowdy it
was like I didn't even see that movie
until it came out on DVD basically so I
feel you with that and the way the movie
unfolds especially towards the middle
like if you're distracted by other
people there's definitely stuff you're
gonna gonna miss in this new movie well
we got a one star let's see how this
goes I just got done watching insidious
last key guys it's really terrible
you like insidious one let's stay away
from it yeah okay but the writing
doesn't give them anything to do a black
mark in the series history so for dank
not please this you know I'll give you
that there is definitely some of the
writing for sure that is a lot thinner
than some of the other writing I don't
agree that they give them nothing to
work with however there are a lot of
people who show up in this movie who
don't get much to work with I mean Elise
Tucker in specs and a couple of the
ghost figures are the ones who get the
most to do and that's a fair point it
could definitely use some more balance
I'll give you I don't think it's
terrible though by any stretch as
prequels go
I think insidious really does a good job
this won't answer some questions and it
kind of fills in the empty spaces that's
a thing I've seen some divisive
responses to because I know a lot of
people kind of hated the shrill
soundtrack but since they've removed a
lot of that from this movie I see a lot
of people really missing it which is
funny to me I don't know if this is a
favorite necessarily for me out of the
franchise but I don't think some of the
best moments are in here and there are
some moments that are probably some of
my favorites out of all four of them for
sure and it does answer a few questions
I will give you that especially
discussing like Star Wars and JJ Abrams
so much lately
I do gotta appreciate that they don't
open up a puzzle box or bring up a cool
question with no intent of answering it
with these movies usually whatever weird
thing they bring up they have an idea as
to how to pay off even if you don't like
that idea I do that I applaud them for
that because the mysteries are actually
sort of rewarding guys I just saw in
cities Laskey and I can say it was all
right it was the best I've ever seen
obviously because I like the first one
the best way I love this one because I
actually had some comedy in it I loved
the stairs I honestly got me so loved it
comedy yeah I hear a lot of people
complain about the comedy and I do get
it I understand what's not to like about
Tucker and specks because they are sort
of the core from which the comedy in
these films flow but I am happy to see
somebody shout that out just because I
think they're pretty funny most of the
time there were definitely some
cringe-worthy scenes in the new movie
featuring them but I always appreciate
again these movies for bringing comedy
as one of their elements and that helps
with the zany factor so yeah good luck
trying to stay awake for this one it's
very boring beginning 3/4 the picture
with her trying to search for answers to
something that the creatures were coming
out of nowhere with the whole jump scare
thing it was just really lazy horror and
motivation was better
a lot of the better movies funny to hear
Annabelle creation come up in this
conversation because I did get some
vibes of that they do definitely borrow
from the current trend of period piece
throwback horror movies in interludes in
this but if you're not overly invested
in the character of Elise I can see how
this might be a bit boring and yeah like
there are some horror movie jump scares
and stuff I do get that so if you're not
a fan of jump scares I can definitely
see those being a detractor for you
because there are some that do sort of
just come out of nowhere and you're like
oh of course you made me jump well I do
think there are some others that are
pretty clever
I can't begrudge you that complaint
that's that's fair and that's a big
matter of your own personal taste as it
comes to horror
chapter 4 last night and it just was
okay maybe that it was supposedly gonna
be the last one I just wish I would have
concluded it a little better than they
did you know I guess I can see that I'm
sort of unclear as to where this falling
if this is gonna be the last one or not
I mean they've they've done well with it
so I wouldn't be surprised if it wasn't
the last one at least wasn't the last
one before they you know decide to
revitalize it later and yeah like this
is the conclusion of the series and I
can definitely see you being a little
bit let down by some of it just because
it is an uneven movie but on the other
hand if it is the last outing for this
series I mean I do like what they chose
to dedicate that to if that makes any
sense and there is a lot of stuff that's
successful in that guys got a cool
dinosaur head I like that that's
actually something that's kind of
curious to me too is you know watching
the first one and the fourth one I can
almost see how that might be a different
experience because the first one is just
the introduction to everything that's
insidious and then your very next
impression is diving directly into the
character of you know the medium I kind
of wish I could have in an alternate
universe experienced it that way just to
see what it might have been like but and
to see you know somebody skipping from 1
to 4 and still enjoying it a lot is kind
of a neat thing so yeah I don't know it
seems like the reactions on this movie
are pretty mixed overall but few people
seem to like flat-out hated even the
capsule responses I've seen on rotten
tomatoes that are rotten are like whoa
it's not without certain high points you
know like that everybody's pointing out
something you appreciate even if they
don't like the movie very much overall
I'm happy to see them do surprisingly
well with this especially if it is the
last outing it feels cool to dedicate
that to the kind of heart and soul of
the franchise over time yeah keep on
truckin old bah anyway you guys can
subscribe to the reel rejects click that
notification bell to get updated every
time a review or a video is out follow
us first on the startups tab click the
link below to download that and if you
love us and you want to come join us in
a more personal environment check out
our patreon until next time peeps
my name is John - Cheers